there's a new exploit been discovered
for Linux which has got the wonderful
names of a dirty cow as an unprivileged
user it enabled me to get root access to
the system and then I'll be able to
completely destroy it and so so I'm
running Debian Linux VM it's not limited
just a debian basically any version of
Linux that's been released over the last
ten years what we're going to do is show
that the exploit will give us a root
shell and then we can do some things
that perhaps we shouldn't so I'm gonna
first of all show by trying to change
the root password that I don't have any
permissions more than the normal user so
I can't change the root password I'm not
going to run the exploit it goes and
does its stuff and boom it's giving me a
root shell and so I can now if I move
the right file back in I can change the
root password to lemonade
copies the password file back in to the
right place log out of root and now back
at the login prompt and I can log in as
root with my password as lemonade so
I've managed to root my VM all using the
dirty cow export well to understand how
it works we actually need to understand
a little bit about how the Linux kernel
handles memory because what's actually
happening here is we're exploiting a
method the mechanism that Linux uses to
handle its memory and deserve what's
called a race condition in there that
when you exploit it enables you to
overwrite files that you shouldn't
normally have access to so ones that you
can read say things like the password
for the password program or SATA Tetra
password you can read them which is fine
as you need to but you shouldn't be able
to modify them so the first thing we
need to think about is how linux manages
memory now looks at how memory works in
the computer before what most modern
operating systems including Linux
Windows macros etc do is that the memory
that the process uses is a sort of
logical address space that only exists
to that process the operating system
actually thinks about it in terms of
pages these are for K blocks of memory
which is then maps in and out is
necessary this is how you can do virtual
memory and things and pass things in and
out
this when you need it so if you think
about our program it's got its memory
address space and we'll say it's got
memory location zero here and then that
goes up to however much is using
generally you will also have other bits
where the operating system is mapped in
as well so it's got its first page there
then its second page and so on and as
far as the process is concerned these
are all continuous in memory so that's
location 0 then that's for K later this
is 8k 60 and K 64 K and so on so it just
sees a flat memory address space which
you can write into in these pages what
the operating system is doing on the
other hand is it's thinking about the
physical memory and with the help of the
CPU it's got a translation table so this
is the logical view of the process and
this is the actual physical memory so
what happens in the operating well
actually when it loads the program in it
Maps that one saying to that physical
page this one may get mapped into that
one this one may get mapped into them
they don't have to be in order but
inside the CPU there's a translation
table which is set up by the operating
system when this process is in memory
that says map these pages into this
location and everything works absolutely
fine
now one of the things you can then do is
say well actually say this page here has
exactly the same data in it as another
page in a different process so rather
than having to use two different memory
locations in actual memory to have the
same things you can have them both point
at the same bit of memory and will have
the other process off here points to the
same block and if all they ever do is
read from that memory location that's
absolutely fine because they can both
read from it they share it there's no
changes the problem comes to say this
process wants to modify something in
that memory location and in that case
what happens is the Linux kernel detects
it is modifying it so it's no longer the
same between the two processes and says
ok I will copy this one in to this page
here this physical page here and update
the translation table
so we now point there's and because
we've changed it they're now pointing at
two separate locations this is what's
called copy-on-write because we copy it
make the copy when we write to the file
which is where we get the cow part of
dirty cow so that's what the
copy-on-write does and that process will
copy the page and modify it so what
actually happens with the dirty cow
exploit is it uses this copy-on-write
facility but it also does something else
as well as just being able to use the
memory because the way linux works you
can also map a file off disk directly
into memory and the various page
faulting mechanisms are used to handle
virtual memory will then load it in when
it's accessed because we've got access
to read the file we can write it into
memory and read it so we can read the
file in there so we'll map the file that
we want to modify in to say these memory
blocks here and these get mapped to
various pages in real memory as soon as
we start reading them or writing to them
so what we do is we map this file into
memory and we map it simplifying the
explanation somewhat in such a way that
it's mapped so that when you gets
written to it activates the
copy-on-write
so we're going to make it maps as in
private fashion so when we write to the
file we get a copy on write happening we
then do two things we set up two threads
running on the computer one of which is
repeatedly telling the operating system
that we no longer need these bits of
memory so saying we no longer need this
bit of memory you can page it out and
use it for something else
in which case normally you telling it
doesn't need it so it reused the
physical memory reversing so one of the
things a computer you can do because
it's got this translation table and
because it knows when you're accessing
it is take some of it write it back out
to disk and then modify load something
else in for another process and then
swap them in and out is how virtual
memory works so you can do that behind
the scenes and the operating system does
that so you're telling it you no longer
need this memory so it's a candidate to
be mapped out so you're doing that in
one thread then in another thread Linux
provide
access to the memory as a special file
on disk and so you open that file up and
you write the new data that you wanted
to go into that file to the memory
locations where you'd map that file into
memory so you just write the data you
want to go there
you do these things many times a second
and eventually there's a possibility in
the Linux kernel that the overlap of the
two routines happens in such a way that
the file gets updated and modified is
changed and so the copy-on-write says oh
this is change was no longer needed I
better write this out to disk and
because this is happening as the kernel
it can write to any file regardless of
permissions so write to the update out
to disk modifying the file that the
actual program didn't have the
permission to access there was all being
that we can change the file on disk that
we shouldn't be able to and get
ourselves a root shell or whatever it is
we wanted to do with it and the reason
is because the two parts of the
operating system one that is writing to
the memory and the other bit which is
doing the copy-on-write
and not sufficiently into the even
interlocked so that they don't actually
stop the thing and we got what's called
a race condition between the two parts
so basically it's exploiting this race
condition so it's kind of setting two
things in motion that kind of get out of
sync is that yeah pretty much the way
that implemented is such that the two
parts of the operating system one which
is writing to the memory and the other
bit which is doing the copy-on-write
and not sufficiently into the even
interlocked so that they don't actually
stop the thing and we got what's called
a race condition between the two parts
I've also seen it crash the kernel when
trying it as well so it's perhaps not as
easy as all that it's a sufficiently
serious book that if you could ever get
access to a shell on a system you could
probably if it's not been patched get up
too and get a root shell and then do
some real damage install a Trojan use it
to form a botnet whatever it is you
wanted to do so if you've got a Linux
system go and patch it and if there
isn't a patch out for it unplug it from
the network or make sure it's well
firewalled
but it's a sufficiently serious burg
that anything where you can get access
to a root shell can I just it's a
sufficiently serious bugs and accident
it's a sufficiently serious bill that's
a tongue twister if ever there was one